how can you be unique this is a great
question I got asked by someone on
YouTube ahead running to say every time
start my own software development
company please advise me on how it can
be unique and how to attract customers
by giving them value this is a great
question to hand and for me at the end
of the day the most important thing when
you're marketing yourself is people want
to learn of what you stand for they want
to know not so much about what you sell
but who you are what you believe it's a
really noisy world it's a really
complicated world and you don't have a
lot of time to stand out in people's
minds and they're not gonna go and say
hey here's another software developer
you have to go with so hey why would
they say that
you gotta give them a reason right you
gotta make them feel something so what
is that in my view you have to find the
one word that makes you stand down the
one word that makes you unique that will
attract people and that will help guide
all your business decisions so for me
it's believed my saying on my videos
what content is all about believe it's
easy to understand it's easy to say he's
the believe guy here's another example
okay a buddy of mine was just with me
here in Orlando I'm in an alignment now
I'm super sick down a mighty and poppin
advils and topping a lot bit so Louie
Louie was here for a couple days he runs
a company called last minute training he
those training tells computer training
you know you want to take an excel
course you want to take a powerful
course whatever it is he'll sell it to
you what a you know boring industry
nobody cares about buying training it's
a it's a it's a you know it's the last
thing that a lot of people's minds it's
not a sexy industry and how does Louis
stand out Louie believes in providing
great customer service that's what he
loved he he every time I meet him he is
he is ranting about some company that
screwed him over and how upset he is and
how he never like he does not do that to
his customers and the word that came out
from his conversation was delighted he
wants people to be the light you get off
a call with last minute training you're
gonna be delight you get off an email
with a training you're gonna be
delighted every experience with last
minute training is gonna be delightful
that's who he is
that's his value and he's hired people
who believe the same thing and he's
attracting customers who believe the
same thing too so that's your
challenging what is it what is the the
one word that separates you and it's not
your product or service we know what you
do your selling you know your software
developer great what is it about you
personally that you believe in that
makes me easy for me to talk about you
right this sounds of people sell
training why would I recommend lui
besides him being a friend of mine
they will he's the he'll make you feel
delighted that's easy right that's easy
for me to talk about you want to make it
easy for people to spread your message
so I know tons of software developers
why should I say go hire Saheb what's
the big thing that you stand for you
know if it's reliability doc you'd be
MXC he's the reliable it's off a
developer guy
now you're gonna back that up that's got
to be something that's not just a
marketing thing but something that you I
should believe to your core it's gonna
make you upset when somebody's not
reliable just like it makes Louie upset
when he doesn't get good customer
service so find that word and then
spread that message and incorporate into
everything that you do that'll make it
easy to track customers for people to
talk about you and for you to make all
the important decisions need to make in
your business believe those you watch
you like your video thumbs up below
leave a comment ask a question tell me
to feel better and click on my face if
you wanna subscribe to the channel
thanks so much I'll see you soon